[Music]
Lonard is with us in miami Filan art how
are you
good afternoon mr. Ramsey thank you for
taking my call
sure how can I help well I believe
yesterday I got a call from a debt
collector and they're trying to pursue a
settlement on a payday loan that was
taken out in my name but I've never
received funds from it I've never
applied for a payday loan and I just
wanted to know what's the best way to
handle this situation
I would tell them that obviously your
identity has been stolen and that you're
going to need the information to do a
police report with okay and they'll give
you the information and you will file a
police report and then you'll have to
fill out an affidavit with the payday
lender and some paperwork just to say
it's not me and I'm not paying it you
don't have my signature on file I did
not sign anything you may have my name
you might even have my social security
number and so the you know if it is if
it is in reality
identity theft you'll begin to discover
that and I would rush to Xandar
insurance and get there Xander insurance
identity theft protection plan in place
as soon as possible because they will
provide a counselor to you that will do
all the work to solve this if it comes
up again they might even help you solve
this one okay now okay that's one
possibility the Xander I would do period
okay immediately the the one possibility
is is that your identity has been stolen
and that they have your social security
number over there and you didn't give it
to them and someone signs your name and
it's not your signature right that's
identity theft and that's at the payday
lender if that's the case the payday
lenders on the up-and-up and when you
provide a police report and you know go
over and fill out whatever paperwork you
need to to prove to them that it is not
you and you're not going to pay this you
do not owe it
then they will mark it off the books is
something where they got ripped off okay
another possibility is the payday
lending business is so scummy and
there's such a fringe element around
some of it that the POC there is a
possibility that they don't even have a
file on you they're just making phone
calls trying to collect money from
people that doesn't even know it they
they may not have your numbers they may
not have your name I think that's your
name and phone number from somewhere all
right but I mean they made their there
are cases where people call up and try
to collect a bill that there's not even
identity theft it's just a fraudulent
attempt at collection it's just a scam
in other words and you may find out that
that's what it is but I would say
there's less than a 10% chance of that
90% chance that it is actually identity
theft and a hundred percent chance that
if I was in your shoes I would get
xander insurance in place immediately
for the or Xander protection plan for
identity theft in place immediately I've
and I'll me my wife all my kids all my
team every 700-plus team member that
works here gets a family plan with them
to cover their whole family identity
theft is just rampant and to not have
coverage on it where someone comes in
and does the work for you to clean up
the mess is just crazy because it's just
too rampant it's too out there and I
would do that I mean you can do all the
work but the average identity theft
folks it for those of you listening out
there I mean the average person you
spend about 600 hours cleaning up these
things because you'll have 10 or 20 of
these accounts pop up that aren't you
and you got to go clean them all up and
prove them all and get the police report
done and fill out the affidavits and do
all that stuff you don't owe any money
to someone to it to a bank or to a
credit card company you don't owe any
money when someone steals your identity
and does business with them it's their
fault they took a false account they
didn't prove it was you they didn't go
in and do it so they're the ones gonna
lose the money you don't hold money but
boy they fight you and the first thing
they do is start treating you like you
did something wrong when you didn't do
anything I've never even been in your
building I've never even interactively'
you people on the internet I don't even
know who
you are I'm not paying a dime I can
promise you so you do not owe the money
it's not that it's not the actual
savings of dollars
it's the savings of all the hassle in
time you have to go through to get the
mess cleaned up that's the problem with
identity theft is the number of hours
and really harsh and ridiculous
conversations that you have to have with
people who are just not smart on the
other end of the phone they're called
collectors